cheaters can reach speeds of up to 110
kilometers an hour so here this cheater
is barely breaking a sweat but then he's
only chasing a toy Romeo you've been fed
already the cheetah Outreach Center in
Cape Town is home to 11 of these big
cats they were brought in from ethical
breeding programs where they were hand
raised so none of them are wild the
cheetahs are kept in captivity so that
they can serve as ambassadors for their
wild cousins it gives visitors the
chance to bond with the Predators well
cheetahs especially their non aggressive
they are running on a fighter and for us
to show that you can have this amazing
relationship and bond with a with a wild
predator and if they can learn to trust
us and live in harmony with us we should
be able to be able to share the same
emotional maturity and learn how to live
with them as well cheetah numbers have
fallen drastically from around 100,000
just over a century ago to a little over
7,000 today farmers pose the greatest
threat to these big cats almost 2,000
kilometers away farmer Mornay Brimmer
prepares to release his flock of goats
for the day it's not always been easy
letting them roam in the past animals
have been lost which is quite difficult
to farming we've got cheetah we've got a
lion coming through occasionally leopard
caracal jackal there's those numerous
predators in this area many farmers
killed the Predators to protect their
livestock but Bremer was offered another
option
cheetah outreach gave him a dog and not
just any dog when integrated with the
flock as puppies Anatolian guard dogs
are fiercely protective
today Brimmer is visiting the dog
breeding center the program provides
farmers with the dog for free and pays
for its upkeep for one year now there's
even a waiting list for the animals
cheetah outreach project manager Deon
Silius has come to to see how the dogs
are doing the Anatolian Shepherd is
quite a huge dog
he's quite bold and he stands back from
nothing they are not attack dogs they
are not aggressive at all and they would
just start barking when a Predator is
around and usually that's enough to
scare predators away back in Cape Town
schools often visit to learn about the
organization's activities and the dog
project education plays a big role in
the work of cheetah outreach most
children in this part of South Africa
will never get to see a cheetah in the
wild the big cat can be found in the
northern provinces but not this far
south then being in captivity is a very
important role to play in terms of the
preservation of their wild cousins
through the awareness the education
conservation of a genetic pool of
cheetahs because there are so few of em
left in the world
cheetahs are already listed as
vulnerable by the International Union
for the Conservation of Nature for a
species coming ever closer to the brink
wild cheetahs need all the help they can
get to ensure they have a future in
South Africa and beyond
you